dopo l'ultimo mostratami sono arrivati
molti commenti riguardanti twitter o per
meglio dire l'argomento commentare con
poche parole perché io ho criticato il
fatto che non si potesse parlare di film
con pochissimi caratteri e monta gente
giustamente mi ha detto ma anche tu lo
fai con il tuo twitter
e hanno ragione quindi mi sono detto
perché non farlo perché non parlare di
film con pochissime parole e allora sono
andato su facebook e ho detto alla gente
scrivetemi un commento
una piccolissima recensione o soltanto
un giudizio di un film che preferite
meglio se ironico e con il minor numero
di parole possibili tra i migliaia di
commenti che vi sono arrivati
ho preso una manciata di quelli più
belli di o aggiunti ai miei hanno fatto
questo video in poche parole volkscamp
sì ma io le ho chiesto se passava quando
dici non è che doveva raccontarmi la
storia della sua vita il grande gatsby e
i soldi comprano tutto o quasi
matrix ho capito qualcosa ma solo dopo e
memento non si capisce un cazzo neanche
qui però il mio film preferito twilight
l'unico film dove lei ha moglie lui no e
proprio fantasy 300 l'alba di un impero
il film e m
ma eva green e daredevil e ti storia di
un alieno che dopo una sbronza si
ritrova senza soldi scrocca una
telefonata tra bossi però stai calmo e
che cazzo si per vendetta il film degli
anonymous no the departed ama quindi
finisce così ovvio il cavaliere
anche io voglio avere michael cheika vi
pulisce casa hunger games il grande
fratello che vorremmo fight club
ok adesso l'ho visto c'era il freddo un
po no terminator 2 viaggerà nel tempo si
può per un avatar che ha un cielo più
grosso vince pro chi perché risulta non
ha perso avengers e come il carnevale ma
senza carne harry potter è il mio primo
giorno come schifo faccia sapere tutte
ste cose piton di mercenari ragazzo ai
chuck norris i mercenari 2 a eccolo
fatte star wars in una galassia lontana
lontana succede quello che succede qui
però con le spade laser o poi la figlia
pacific rim
dunque ci shinji che a noi spetta
scarface
se al vaccino avesse starnutito sarebbe
arrivata la neve a miami paranormal
activity youtube nel 2007 praticamente
l'esorcista malanno più ritrovato un
crocifisso lo hobbit non è fedele al
libro e la gol non è fedele al libro
shining
meno male che non è federalismo jumanji
è come giocare a risiko con i carri
armati veri donnie darko voi la carota
pelago solo se mi fai capire il finale
la casa i vecchi proprietari hanno
lasciato un libro bello dylan dog il
film miglia poi uno non si deve
incazzare batman e robin capezzoli sette
anime commovente soprattutto la parte
dove prende per il culo un cieco
la passione di cristo uno dei fantasy
più riusciti di sempre albachiara bejing
no guardi fra una settimana c'è un
impegno con una mia zia non arancia
meccanica è bello sono sette per 8 no mi
dispiace chiudevo tagli alla gamba
americana stampa faber di capelli
ingrassa non entra più nel pack costume
si dà la malavita xxx il film era merda
è però tutti quelli che scarichi prima
per errori non sono male l'alba dei
morti viventi o come si chiama da noi
sanremo la grande bellezza wrobel e la
caduta hitler
nella guerra e si incazza lo riprendono
e caricano il video su youtube per farci
le parodie into the wild
ma gira pagina imbecille alone in the
dark armageddon quando un meteorite
esplode diventa un diablo i passi
dell'amore science sono allergici
all'acqua mai visto degli alieni più
stupidi la guerra dei mondi lo fate
apposta planet terror prima volta che
vedere un pene sciogliersi non ti dà
così fastidio bastardi senza gloria è
finita la sbornia sbagliato tutto devo
rifare shark nato ci vorrebbe una bella
recensione
mai utopici sono generi più pd facebook
e che fanno quel pacco onda frega cazzi